le Mondial de l'UTO Porte de Versailles
est une vitrine pour les constructeurs
ce salon créé en 1898 présente cette
année plus de 270 marques venant de 21
pays parmi elles les constructeurs
installés dans les Yvelines présentation
des nouveautés 2012 ce crossover urbain
qui est derrière nous le 2008 concept ça
c'est une voiture qui sera présentée
commercialisée à l'été prochain donc dès
2013 crossover ça ça va mélanger les
genres ça va prendre le meilleur de la
berline c'est-à-dire la le le la tenue
de route le confort d'une berline mais
ça va lui adjoindre le l'habitabilité
d'un monospace avec le look beaucoup
plus dynamique et moderne d'un SUV d'un
4x4 entre guillemets notamment avec la
présentation de la série une trois
portes du Touring Série 3 et surtout
j'ai envie de dire puisque c'est sa
première mondiale de l'active Tourer qui
est en fait le premier véritable
monospace dans la gamme BMW on commence
par le remplaçant du Kuga le nouveau
Kuga le 44 de la game Ford il y a la
nouvelle Mondeo la future grande berline
le porte-drapeau de la gamme il y a un
tout petit 44 qui s'appelle l'cosport
qui arrivera un petit peu plus tard et à
cela s'ajoute le restyage de la fiesta
et le nouveau Bmax qui sont les voitures
qui vont arriver sur le marché dans les
tout prochains jours dont nous
commençons la commercialisation et qui
augurent déjà d'avoir un succès notable
principalement pour le Bmax qui a la
particularité d'avoir des portes très
innovantes chez Fiat la gamme 500
s'agrandit avec l'arrivée de la 501
destinée aux familles et disponible en
France dès le 10 octobre c'est un
véhicule qu'on a voulu très émotionnel
sur les aspects coloril
elle reprend les quelques éléments
esthétiques de la SA notamment la
planche de bord couleur carrosserie mais
c'est avant tout un véhicule qu'on a
voulu très rationnel avec beaucoup
d'habitabilité pardon de modularité de
la personnalisation et des tarifs et des
équipements à la hauteur la marque
italienne présente également sa panda 44
qui sera commercialisé mi-octobre le
Mondial de l'automobile se tient
jusqu'au 14 octobre il a accueilli
l'année dernière plus d'un million
200000 visiteurs venus du monde
entier